il a remis son tablier et retrouver sa
chère cuisine le temps de mettre un peu
de friture sur la ligne du gouvernement
un plat populaire pour une manifestation
qui l'est tout autant
je suis pourtant de personnes juste bien
moi je veux juste ok mon agent m'en
vouloir je sais pourquoi je suis fait
parce que si demain j'ai plus de raison
d'être en salle les collègues sont
nombreux à venir donner le coup de main
pour dénoncer d aide précieuse mais
insuffisante des assureurs défaillant et
un manque criant de visibilité qu'est-ce
qu'ils font refaire un nom d'un autre
crédit se sont surendettés
dehors la foule solidaire est au rendez
vous la gendarmerie aussi mais pour
d'autres raisons
il s'agit de s'assurer qu'aucun client
ne sera servi ni en salles ni même en
terrasse sous peine de sanctions bruno
le maire l'a dit la désobéissance civile
se fera sans les aides de l'état dont on
n'est pas des enfants on est des adultes
responsables
on n'a pas nous parler comme ça on est
des citoyens on participe au débat
démocratique
on a notre mot à dire et c'est
insupportable d'entendre responsables
politiques de dire dire attention si
vous ouvrez vous aurez des sanctions
aujourd'hui on ne pourra pas leur ouvrir
pourquoi parce que je risque d'aller en
prison d'avoir 2 permet mais
indemnisation de pertes d'exploitations
fermées dès finalement fermé des
visiblement carrément on en est là
l'insurrection restera donc sur sa faim
notamment temporisé par le collectif
restons ouverts qui a exhorté les plus
téméraires à ne pas braver l'interdît au
nom du dialogue avec l'êta une fois que
vous avez rompu le dialogue
il ya plus de dialogue y a plus de
discussions et nous ce qu'on veut pas
c'est que dd reste des chefs comme
stéphane face le geste de trop le geste
qui ferait que demain le 2 février
bah il est fermé la truite de cuzance
fera tout de même son bout de chemin et
qu'elle arrive ou non jusqu'à l'elysée
le symbole reste fort et pour le chef il
a presque le goût de la victoire
moi je suis content j'ai gagné quoi
qu'il arrive j'ai gagné parce que
regarder
regardez les gens ils sont là dans un
village de 70 habitants est le 2 le dos
on continuera le combat parce que le 2
c'est quoi le 2 c'est le jour d'après un
jour d'après encore très sombre
c'est d'ailleurs au pied du mur du
cimetière local que le chef a déposé son
tablier provisoirement en tout cas ils
espèrent
[Applaudissements]